was für ein Bild herrlich das ist pors
am Rhein ja berühmte Söhne hat dieses
kleine Örtchen ist ja eigentlich ein
Stadtteil von Köln aber die Porzer
wollen das nicht so richtig fahr haben
berühmte Söhne sind z.B Mark
metlock meine Wenigkeit klar und Guido
Kanz ja viele haben es vielleicht schon
gesehen er trägt ja gerne mal so ein
T-Shirt mit pororts drauf also hier ist
das so sieht das aus da fährt gerade das
Wappen von Köln ab ja die Weiße Flotte
ist ja heftig unterwegs auf dem rehein
und Guido Kanz der ist bei uns zu Gast
er hat ja jetzt die Moderation von
verstehen sie Spaß in der ARD der großen
Samstagabend Show übernommen und bei uns
steht da Rede und Antwort und zwar auch
wieder euren Fragen den nutzerfragen
seid kreativ wie immer claro und seid
kurz das ist besonders wichtig bitte am
besten nur eine einzige gute Frage da
sind die Chancen am größten dass sie
beantwortet werden also wir sind
gespannt bis dann